Hey yeah thanks everyone
uh yeah so my name's Bryan Hughes
Technical Evangelist at Microsoft like
Vanessa said you can find me at neveri
us on Twitter github and basically
everywhere else and so today I'm gonna
talk about basically like privilege and
tech and kind of really boiling that
down and looking at how that works and
kind of what we can do about it now a
question you might be asking yourself
though before I get into that is why me
why am I actually here talking to you
about this today you know especially as
someone who is pretty privileged you
know it's a good question to ask and I
think two key reasons one is that well
I'm bisexual and I'm an atheist and I
was also born and raised in multiple
places in Texas which is one of the most
conservative places in the entire United
States one of the cities I lived in was
actually ranked as the second most
conservative city in the entire country
so I let you piece together what that
was like growing up it was not pleasant
let's just say a little more recently
though I was involved in the node.js
project for about two years where I
focus specifically on diversity and
inclusivity and the project I helped to
found the inclusivity working group
which was the first group that kind of
was working on culture and then later on
as we kind of restructured some things I
helped to found the community committee
which is the current group that is
responsible for culture in the project
as well as a number of other things so I
like to think that I've learned a few
things along the way throughout all this
process right so privilege this is a
topic that gets in a word that gets
thrown around quite a bit and sometimes
the ingenuously sometimes in less
tenuous ways shall we say and I think
there's a lot of misconceptions about
what it is and what it represents so
want to spend some time boiling that
down it just really talking about what
it actually means in the way it
manifests itself and I'm gonna do so by
making analogies with bug reports
actually because I think they're as it
turns out are actually quite a few
similarities so this is a problem that
we tend to have a lot let's say we've
got a user they're using you know our
product or say or managing an open
source project and so these users are
using our library so they try and use
this thing and they run into problems
they get a cryptic error message when
they try to log in to a site maybe the
library is crashing on startup you know
whatever it is something got in the way
a bud got in the way of the user being
able to use our product and so you know
this is bad enough that they go and they
file a support issue or they open an
issue on github and they say hey I'm
trying to use your thing and it's not
working so you is the engineer you know
you pick up this bug and you go and you
try to reproduce it so you know you
follow the same steps they did to get to
it and well it just works for you
right you can't reproduce this bug at
all it works on your machine so mark the
bug as closed can't reproduce and move
on we've all been there I have certainly
done that a number of times in my
engineering career so far but there's
like two sort of simultaneous truths
that I think are important to keep in
mind the first one is that it's true it
worked
for you like you know it worked on our
machines and so you know we are not
encountering that bug ourselves like
that is absolutely true the other thing
that is also true at the same time is
that this user that was using the
library or product or whatever did
encounter that bug like that bug exists
right even if we can't reproduce it that
bug still exists and the reason this
typically happens is because the context
of the user like the technical context
of the user is different than the
technical context of you you know we
typically tend to develop on really you
know new fast MacBook Pros or something
similar to that like we have powerful
machines that are new we also typically
have very fast internet access and a lot
of times users don't necessarily have
that you know they might have a
ten-year-old Dell running yo Windows 7
that is like heavily locked down and
perhaps they have really poor internet
speeds or very intermittent internet you
know there's these differences in
context this technical context that
caused the user to encounter the bug and
we didn't you know it could have been
say a race condition in our code but
this race condition was only exposed
whenever the performance was slow enough
for the network was slow enough and so
it was like the bug absolutely exists in
the code regardless of whether or not we
encountered it and the difference is
that context and that's basically what
privileges in a
in a nutshell it's the case where we
exist in a context in the broader world
you know we live in the country we lived
and we had the parents that we had with
their financial situation you know we
are the gender we are they are the
ethnicity we are we are the sexual
orientation we are and so on and so
forth so like we all exist within these
contexts and there's a lot of bugs in
society you know bugs that trace back
thousands and thousands of years and so
depending on the context that we live in
we may or may not encounter these bugs
in society and that's what privilege is
is when we exist in a context that
allows us to sidestep this bug
oftentimes without us even realizing
that we have done that and one thing I
would note is there is nothing you know
there's not a value judgment that I'm
placing on the person here just like you
know we don't judge the value of a
person based on whether their employer
issued them a new MacBook Pro or an old
dell laptop like that doesn't say
anything about the person but that is
the context and that is how they view
the world at the same time so speaking
of contacts a lot of times like as
engineers we don't know what the users
context is at least not fully you know
the user files this bug you know we
hopefully will figure out you know what
browser they're running on you know for
really lucky we'll figure out which
browser version in which operating
system and we oftentimes don't know the
rest we don't know what their ISP is we
especially don't know what their
networking conditions were at the time
of that bug and sometimes there's even
things that could contribute to the bug
that we don't even know are things that
could contribute to a bug a really good
example actually ran into one last week
when I was doing some technical work I
was working with Asher file storage
which is a way of storing files in the
cloud pretty straightforward I was
following the documentation and I'm
trying to connect to the service to
upload some files and I just couldn't
connect I was trying everything reading
the documentation following the steps in
the azure documentation and what
should've work just was not working for
me
turns out it was actually a problem with
my ISP they were blocking port 445
outbound and I didn't even realize that
like I didn't even think to think about
that problem and I spent about a day on
it until I realized what was going on
and so a lot of times you know it's not
that we just that we don't know the
users context but we don't know the
things
that we don't know that are contributing
to the bug so that's basically what this
concept of unconscious biases so in
society there's a lot of times a lot of
things that affect certain groups of
people that we don't even think or we
aren't even aware of that is an actual
problem
I think perhaps a good example of this
is if we there have been some studies
that have shown in meetings you know men
tend to talk a lot more than women do
and sort of the intuitive reaction that
a lot of us men will have is that Oh
women should just speak up more but
there's a whole bunch of other things
that actually play into it a lot of
societal dynamics that make that a lot
more complicated and the things that you
know we as men are just not aware of you
know we're unconscious to this and
because we're not aware of them we end
up having these biases that come into
play now like I said this is unconscious
if we're not doing this on purpose at
all but it is still there so another
thing that we tend to see a lot is that
a lot of small bugs can add up to really
big frustrations you know I think we've
all used these services you know we
start we log in for the first time we
might encounter a small bug along the
way say we log in it goes through a
redirect flow from off and that redirect
just like stalls in the middle for some
reason you know we may not know why but
it just it sticks and so you know we
have to go up manually hit that refresh
button and then it loads and goes along
its merry way that's a bug it's not a
very big one it's a small detail you
know it didn't get in the way of us
using our product well that's just kind
of annoying but then we logged it then
once we're in we start encountering a
lot more of these little things you know
maybe there's a label that's just kind
of cutting off screen a little bit or
maybe there's a button that you had to
click on twice before it'll actually
activate you know once again every
single one of these bugs is a low
priority bug but when added up together
they add up to a really big frustrating
application you know we tend to say that
these kind of applications like oh that
is so buggy I hate this app you know
it's not we don't approach this as like
oh yeah there's a bunch of little things
but overall the app is great no that's
not how our brains actually work you
know that each of those bugs sort of
they they're not even just like a linear
additive thing they kind of multiply
against each other
and it becomes a really serious issue
and you know we end up lose
users and things like that so that's
basically what the concept of
microaggressions is so what
microaggression is something where
someone will do something to an
underprivileged person that just kind of
adds up to a little bit I think a
classic example of this is whenever we
use the word guys to refer to all
developers like viewed in a vacuum this
is not that big of a deal yeah you know
there's definitely much worse things
that a lot of people have to face you
know such as like wage disparity and
discrimination things like that so in
the grand scheme of things saying guys
isn't that big of a deal when viewed in
a vacuum
but the thing is it doesn't exist in a
vacuum
it exists in this broader context you
know it is one of those you know little
bugs that adds up to a really bad
application you know it's death by a
thousand paper cuts and so you know I
think it's really important that we
remember that you know these little
things do matter even if they don't seem
like a big deal because in aggregate
it's just a further reminder that you
know underprivileged people are in fact
underprivileged so another thing that we
tend to see a lot especially you know if
you've done a lot of open source work
you'll see this is that users rarely
report bugs it was something I'm
actually guilty of myself I was even
chatting with Anna last night about this
you know we encounter a bug we get kind
of frustrated by it but we just move
along you know we could take the time
out of our day to open an issue on
github or file an issue with the support
team but we usually don't and because
our time is valuable and so we're always
doing these little judgment calls in our
head of should I invest my time to see
that someone else fixes the problem by
reporting this issue or bug and the
answer is almost always now sometimes
it's yes but it's almost always no so
when we look at what is being reported
you know we have to remember that this
is sort of a represent a small
representation of much bigger problems
that you know this is a fraction of the
actual bugs users encounter and we see
the same thing when we're talking about
culture issues as well and so is the way
I tend to say it is like when we see an
underprivileged person who is calling
out bad behavior this is never
the first offense it's the first Hill
worth dying on so well when I say that
I'm basically saying that someone goes
public writes a blog post let's say
condemning a company for certain bad
behavior there's oftentimes this
instinctual reaction that you know
people working on the company tend to
have and that's to dismiss it we say
like okay well that person had a problem
but well it's because of yada yada
whatever reasons that come up and most
important let's say and no one else
complained you know we say like well
okay so you know this career person was
complaining about homophobia and company
but yo there's all these other creepy
people and they didn't say anything
therefore it should be fine but that's
not how it actually works what was going
on with those individuals with those
other queer folks is that you know we
were doing that analysis in our head and
being like is it worth it to call this
out is it worth the lost time in
productivity perhaps even you know loss
of respect loss of job even in some
cases that go along with it and a lot of
times the answer is actually no like you
know I certainly see stuff on a pretty
regular basis that you know it makes me
uncomfortable it makes me feel isolated
and singled out as a queer person in a
mostly straight world but I ignore it I
don't call it out I just kind of go on
my way because you know I'll analyze the
situation and realize it's not worth it
and so it's important to realize that
when we see someone who is calling
something out it's not just that this is
a thing that happened it's that a thing
that happened that was bad enough that
it crossed this threshold where it
became worth it to call it out so
there's a numbers game there's an
aggregate game going on here so that's
kind of a couple of the core concepts
that go into you like why we have a lot
of the disparities that we have in tech
and in societies and as a whole but what
do we do about it there's a lot of
different things we can do and so I'm
gonna focus on a very specific aspect
and this is what we can do as
individuals there's entire conversations
we had about what large organizations
and companies can do but that's a
different talk and the big thing we can
do is to develop empathy and so empathy
is a word that gets thrown around a lot
and it can mean a lot of
different things depending on context
but in short empathy is whenever we can
emotionally relate to another person you
know we are technically it is we are
feeling what another person is feeling
and it's having that shared experience
now in practice you know no one will
ever feel exactly what another person is
feeling but you know we'd get a rough
idea it's about you know kind of bonding
together and creating a shared
experience even though we are different
we exist in different contexts within
the world and so a way that I like to
think about it is that we have you know
the privileges that we have and every
single person has some privilege in some
form or fashion every single person in
this room does have privilege and once
again like I said earlier this is not a
value judgment on you as an individual
like having privilege in and of itself
is not a bad thing it's just a state of
being what matters is what we do with
that and how we act on that that's what
really matters
but so everyone has privilege and it
forms this way that we view the world it
colors every interaction we have in
everything we see and so I like to think
of it it's like a lens it's like looking
through a pair of binoculars you know we
can see one little thing really really
well but we can't see everything that
exists beside it you know we're missing
most of the world but we have a lot of
insight into this one small part that we
can see and everyone's lens is different
just like everyone's privilege is
different so the way everyone sees the
world is different we are seeing
different things and there actually can
be I think a lot of power in that
because if we can really develop our
empathy then we this is how we create
this lens to someone else like the lens
we have is to the lens we have there's
nothing we can really do to change that
innately but we can talk to someone else
who has a different lens we can form a
relationship with them we can create a
bond with them so that we can together
hopefully create a fuller picture of
what's going on we can start to see the
world in 360 degrees and so the thing
about empathy some people do think all
right it's often expressed at least that
empathy is just a natural trait we have
either you have it or you don't there
can be some true
to that but empathy is also a skill that
can be nurtured it's a skill that can be
developed and grown and I think I'm
actually a pretty good example of this
in the past when I was a lot younger I
really was did not have very much
empathy and I wasn't very good at
expressing that but it's something I've
been working at you know pretty hard
over the last I don't 10 years or so
maybe 7 years something like that and
I'm by no means perfect of course but
you know I have certainly made a lot of
progress and I think this is something
we all can do and there's a lot of
different ways that we can really work
on training our empathy as well way too
much to go over into a talk here but I'm
gonna give three specific tips you know
like if there's anything that you can
remember about how to kind of work on
your empathy it's these three things the
first thing is to listen to you and
believe marginalize people whenever they
say that there's an issue you know like
I said we all have a different lens we
and we exist in these different context
so whenever someone else is saying that
you know there's a problem you know at
our company we have a culture problem
this company on our team and it's
project our first reaction shouldn't be
to say like oh that's not a problem I'm
not experiencing that I mean
unfortunately this is what we often do
though this is how our brains work this
is how human beings are just kind of
wired we always Center ourselves and
everything we do because we are the only
person where we have a complete
understanding of our own experiences so
our first reaction typically is to say
well I don't have that problem therefore
it's not a problem but that's not how it
works because we exist in these
different contexts and sometimes we
encounter these societal bugs and
sometimes we don't
based on that context so what we should
do instead is to start by recognizing
that this person exists in a different
context I may not be experiencing that
issue myself but they are and so that
issue does exist you know just like
whenever a user reports a bug our first
reaction should be to believe the user
that the bug exists you know and then we
could do some investigation and figure
out how together we can actually try to
make things better
so yeah just try to really work on that
innate reaction to say oh that's not a
problem because I'm not experiencing it
and replace that instead with oh that's
interesting and it's like oh I see
you're experiencing
this or you're telling me that tell me
more about that because I don't
experience that and I don't quite
understand what's going on so listen and
believe first the next bit of advice I
have is to put your ego aside because
really it's not about you as an
individual you know these bugs that we
have in society have existed for
thousands of years you know there is
basically the whole of human history
that has led to a lot of the societal
issues that we have now like this is not
about the individual this really is
about systemic issues you know systemic
issues means it's a bug in the system so
you know whenever you know a person of
color is calling out white people for
racism as an example you know this isn't
like we are criticizing you know John
Smith specifically this is saying like
there are these - semuc issues that
pervade all of society that's some when
we hear that you know try to not feel
personally attacked because it's not a
personal attack you know unless you're
someone who is say on the shitty medium
in list or something like that in that
case okay maybe it is about you but
assuming you're not an [ __ ] like that
which I hope none of you are then
realize that this is much bigger than
any individual so try not to get
defensive it once again it's human
nature to get defensive when someone is
criticizing us but you know just like
whenever we're working on a pull request
like a really good skill as an engineer
when we get critical feedback in a pull
request is not to get angry at the
person who gave us that feedback but
instead to go fix our code you know and
update our pull request exact same thing
here really is we're getting feedback
and then we want to work on this
together to improve things and finally
the last tip I have is to actively work
to create inclusive teams so the thing
about creating like inclusive and
diverse teams is that they don't happen
on their own they take work like it
takes work to get different types of
people together you know we have network
effects you know we tend to typically
know people who are mostly like us so if
we want to bring in people to our team
that are not like us you know we have to
work a little harder at it and it's
just about getting people there it's
also making sure that people stay as
well and so you know not only do we have
to reach out to more people to build
these better teams we have to work on
our culture you know just like creating
a really good culture around a pool
request takes working and we have to get
over that defensiveness and instead you
know work towards you know more of a
common good we have to do that when
we're creating inclusive teams as well
and that's also another topic where that
would take me a couple of talks to
really go through but just you know I'll
say it takes work there's a lot of
resources out there as well where you
can figure out how to do that and we
really want to do this because we are so
much stronger together than we are apart
there's been a lot of studies that have
come out that have shown that when you
control for other variables more diverse
teams will always outperform less
diverse teams like there's a very very
strong correlation there and so you know
when we talk about building inclusive
and diverse teams you know we're not
just doing this for the sake of a metric
or the sake of some statistics we want
to do this because it makes things
better genuinely better and you know
when we kind of think about on this it
actually makes a lot of sense
you know especially when we take this
lens view of the world you know we're
trying to solve problems and a lot of
the problems that we're trying to solve
with our products and our province or
projects are hard problems and in order
to fix a problem in order to solve a
problem we first have to understand it
and so we gain a better understanding of
any given problem if we can get people
who view those problems in different
ways you know they have these different
lenses in different ways of looking at
things so we get more diverse teams in
place we solve problems faster and we
solve them more completely because we
have a better understanding and I'm not
saying this is easy you know it's not
just you get a more diverse team than
its unicorns and rainbows it is hard
because we get these more diverse teams
that means our ideas are going to be
challenged more not less but that's a
good thing
I mean having our ideas be challenged is
not easy it's tough you know once again
we get defensive and reactive we don't
like people saying that we're wrong but
that's actually kind of the point though
is that you know when people are saying
well I don't think this is right you
know and we're saying the same thing
back we're all challenging each other we
get rid of the bad idea
as quickly and we'd get to those good
ideas a lot faster we create better
products we create more well-rounded
products and things like that but this
is also even more than just a business
case you know when we create these more
diverse teams you know we're bringing
more people to the table we're uplifting
all of society and not just a single
segment in it I think there's all these
kinds of network effects that we get
whenever we're just bringing more people
into the fold and you know as we've seen
there's oftentimes a lack of talent in
engineering you know it's hard to find
people to fill roles we need more people
and if we can start reaching out to more
people to fill those roles that need to
be filled not only are we getting the
people we need we're able to build
better products and at the same time and
we're just we're helping out a lot of
these individuals too we're addressing a
lot of these systemic issues that we
have Asus's in society so hopefully we
can get to a point someday where we
actually are working on fixing these
bugs and society and there's a lot of
ways to do that like I said before if
you want to learn more Mozilla has an
inclusion lounge that's going on there's
a panel discussion going on right after
this in fact and I'm gonna be there and
with that I want to thank you all for
listening
you